welcome to the ultimate go-to guide for
choosing an iPad in 2019 now that the
new iPad air and iPad Mini are available
Apple's 2019 iPad lineup is complete
alongside the 2018 budget iPad and 2018
iPad pro and I personally think this is
it until next year there's no reason for
Apple to update the budget iPad until
next year since they'll have to raise
the price into the iPad minis territory
insane for the iPad pro since the
hardware is already way ahead of the
current iOS software so with four iPads
in the lineup how in the world do you
choose one well I'm confident that by
the end of this video you'll be able to
make up your mind we're gonna have links
to the best deals on each of these iPads
in the description below so make sure to
check that out if you make up your mind
all three non pro iPads look basically
identical on the backside the pro looks
much different with a darker space grey
finish antenna bar at the top in a large
camera bump which none of the other
iPads get but it's for a good reason
as you'll see in a camera comparison the
pro also gets the smart connector on the
back since it uses magnets to attach to
the smart Keyboard in the iPad air is
also the only non pro I pad ever to get
the smart connector the iPad pro is also
the only iPad out of this lineup that
gets four speakers two on the bottom and
two on the top and as you'll hear later
it destroys the others in the sound
comparison another difference is USB see
on the pro but you can't really do much
with it yet but you do get a faster 18
watt charger compared to the old 12 watt
charger that comes with the rest of
these iPads of course the pro gets the
new modern square edge design that also
comes with rounded corners on the
display making the other iPads look
outdated compared to it
however the pro is the only iPad that
doesn't get a headphone jack which sucks
for a lot of people but it makes for the
finish iPad out of the lineup which is
nice but it led to some bengay issues
which I personally haven't experienced
at all the pro has even Bessel's all
around thanks to the removal of touch ID
in the switch to face ID which by the
way works great since there's no knotch
and you can use it in any orientation
even upside down some people still
prefer touch ID though and that's
totally fine the pro has smaller bezels
than the 2018 iPad but both the 2019
iPad air
and many actually have slimmer bezels on
the side moving on to display
differences the new air and many have
literally identical displays but the
mini packs the same amount of pixels
into the smaller 7.9 inch display so it
has the highest pixels per inch out of
the whole iPad lineup and it also
comfortably fits in one hand so it's the
lightest and most portable out of all of
these the 2018 budget iPad is the only
one that doesn't get a fully laminated
display which basically means the
display is glued to the glass this leads
to it looking a little grey lacking deep
blacks like the rest and there's a gap
between the display and the glass which
is noticeable from an angle and
especially while using the Apple pencil
it's also the only one that doesn't have
an anti-reflective coating so you'll
notice reflections a lot more it doesn't
get P three wide color gamut either like
the other iPads which makes for a very
color accurate display with colors that
really pop it also lacks true tone which
automatically adjusts the displays color
balance to match the environment you're
in I personally love true tone so as you
can see the 2018 budget iPad is really
lacking in the display department now
the 2018 iPad pro gets a couple more
things at both 600 nits of brightness
compared to 500 on the 2019 iPads and
around 450 on the budget iPad the iPad
pro also gets promotion which is huge in
my book it allows the display to refresh
at up to 120 Hertz and dynamically go
down to match the frame rate of the
content you're viewing to save battery
life as you can see in the slow-mo clip
the difference in the smoothness of
promotion compared to the other iPads in
this lineup is huge and trust me you'll
feel this difference every day not only
that but promotion lowers the latency of
the Apple pencil as well and you can
easily see the difference compared to
the other iPads in this slow-mo clip
speaking of the Apple pencil all of
these iPads support it but the pro
supports the new Apple pencil 2 which is
better in every way you don't have to
plug it into the side like on the other
iPads it magnetically attaches to the
side and instantly starts pairing and
charging the new matte finish feels a
lot better in the hand and it comes with
a new DoubleTap to switch tools feature
which is incredibly convenient now let's
get into that speaker comparison and
make sure to put on a pair of headphones
[Music]
[Music]
yep the iPad pro sounds much better than
the other iPads before we get into
performance and gaming let's quickly
compare the cameras the pro gets flash
on the rear with a 12 megapixel sensor
compared to eight on the other iPads and
here's a photo comparison between them
the pro looks much better than the
others the pro is also the only one that
can shoot 4k video at 60 frames per
second on the front side the budget iPad
only gets a 1.2 megapixel sensor
compared to 7 on the other iPads so
selfies look horrible compared to the
other ones especially the pro since it
gets portrait mode thanks to the face ID
sensors the pro also gets 5 microphones
instead of 2 on the other iPads so it
sounds much better as well this is a
microphone quality test with a 2019 iPad
air this is a microphone quality test
with the 2018 iPad pro now let's finally
get into performance the budget iPad
only gets 2 gigabytes of RAM compared to
3 on the 2019 iPads and 4 on the pro but
you can also get up to 6 gigabytes on
the pro if you buy the one terabyte
model but it's not worth the cash for
almost everyone the budget iPad gets the
a10 processor compared to the 812 on the
2019 iPads in the a 12 X on the pro the
budget iPads a10 is also the only one
that doesn't come with the knurl engine
getting into the Geekbench 4 benchmark
the budget iPad is way behind the others
in terms of single core and even more
behind in multi-core with the air and
mini
almost doubling the score in the pro
almost tripling the score in the metal
test the air and mini are around 75%
faster than the budget iPad and the iPad
pro is almost 2 times faster than the
2019 iPads in over 3 times faster than
the budget iPad in antutu 3d benchmark
there isn't as big of a difference now
but the iPad pro is still around two and
a half times faster than the 2018 budget
iPad finally for a more realistic test
we exported a one-minute 4k 60p video on
each of the iPads and the iPad pro
finished four times sooner than the
budget iPad it was over twice as fast as
a 2019 iPads this is where you'll
actually feel a difference on the new
iPad pro and now let's talk about gaming
each of these iPads apart from the
budget iPad can run fortnight at high
graphics at 60 frames per second the
budget iPad
only run medium graphics at 30 frames
per second and that's the same story for
other games like asphalt 9 running at 30
instead of 60 like on the more expensive
iPads the graphics are noticeably worse
and I also noticed some dropped frames
while gaming the iPad air mini and pro
all run fortnight and asphalt 9
perfectly at 60 frames per second no
dropped frames are issues at all so the
extra power of the pro isn't really
being used in almost every game on the
App Store out of all of them the iPad
Mini is by far the most comfortable to
hold in the hand while gaming the others
weigh quite a bit more so your hands
will get tired over time let's quickly
mention some other spec differences
before I start recommending which iPad
you should buy the budget iPad gets
Bluetooth 4.2 compared to 5.0 on the
other iPads which also gets simultaneous
dual band Wi-Fi for more bandwidth and a
more reliable connection they also get
gigabit class LTE if you're buying that
model now with all that said which iPad
should you buy well the iPad pro is
obviously the best and most powerful
iPad but is also the most expensive at
$800 the four speakers and pro motion
technology make a huge difference in
daily use but if you're not going to be
doing high-end editing or anything that
can actually use the power of the a 12 X
chip you'll probably be better off
buying the 2019 iPad air if you've got
the extra cash you love the design and
you want to keep it for over five years
the iPad pro may be worth the investment
since software will soon catch up to the
amazing hardware also if you're a
serious artist the laminated display
promotion tech and Apple pencil to make
it the best option for drawing and you
can get the pro in the 12 point 9 inch
size as well now the iPad air is the
best all-around iPad since it gets all
the amazing display tech the 10.5 in
size is great for most people and the
a12 processor is really powerful it can
run most apps and games of the 8 12 X
can it'll also be fast enough for most
photo editing tasks as well the new air
is also the only non Pro iPad that comes
with a smart connector so if you're
planning on getting the smart keyboard
and you don't want to spend the extra
cash on the pro the air is a great
all-around long-term option for the
price now the Mini is literally
identical to the air and almost
everything except that it doesn't get
the smart connector in it
it's the same amount of pixels in a
smaller display so it looks sharper if
you get up close to it it's also $100
cheaper than the air so you can save a
good amount of cash if you're fine with
the small display I'd also like to say
that if you play a lot of games the mini
is the best choice since it's so
comfortable to hold for longer gaming
sessions it's small light and portable
so it'll be a great option for the kids
as well now the budget iPad will also be
a good option for kids
since the non laminated display is
really cheap to replace it's the slowest
out of the bunch the display and cameras
are worse but it's also the cheapest
especially if you can find it for only
$250 on Amazon click the link below to
see if it's still on sale it's a great
budget option for everyone who just
needs a basic iPad to do iPad things and
it'll be fine for most of the popular
games on the App Store well there you
have it if this comparison didn't help
you make a decision comment below with
your specific situation and we'll help
you out if you enjoy this video click
that subscribe button above for more
videos like this one this has been
defeating with Max sec thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]